demande jusqu'à la veille de l'hiver vu
la situation de l'hôpital jours et qu'on
revienne sur l'hôpital quand vous pensez
que le ministre a mis en danger la vie
d'autrui en suspendant 20000 non
vaccinés soignants qui pouvait faire des
tests il ya des autotests tous les mois
j'ai proposé quelque chose parce que je
suis prudent j'ai proposé que les
soignants non vaccinés phase des tests
tous les trois jours un test pas la mort
donc je demande qu'on remette les 20000
soignants suspendu dans l'hôpital qui
est aujourd'hui est en faillite et
aujourd'hui il ya pas que le coc vide il
ya des opérations cancéreuses ou de
tumeurs cancéreuses qui sont repoussés
parce que les blocs opératoires sont
fermés c'est le plus grand scandale
sanitaire donc vous soutenez par exemple
aussi dans le même sujet ces
départements qui refuse de verser le rsa
aux
salariés de deux de l'assemblée rejette
rossa scandaleux je trouve ça scandaleux
qu'on fasse des différences comme ça
ja devant de vue du gouvernement et ses
appartements qu'ils ont c'est scandaleux
c'est une honte abominable non seulement
ces soignants ont été au front ils ont
soigné au moment de l'épidémie alors
qu'ils n'avaient pas de blouse pas de
masque on les jette comme des chiens on
en a besoin
les blocs opératoires sont fermées parce
que monsieur vers en suspens des
soignants non vaccinés qui pourrait se
faire tester ces départements mais il
faut que ces désistements bien
évidemment il faut surtout qu'ils soient
réintégrés par l'hôpital pour sauver des
malades il n'y a pas que le coc vide il
ya je voyais encore il ya une très belle
enquête dans le figaro ce matin qu'ils
disent que je disais il ya deux mois
quand même ce qui est quand même
incroyable c'est que on le disait il ya
deux mois on est une poignée de
sénateurs une poignée de députés et on a
alerté et le ministre par idéologie par
sectarisme
volontairement saborder l'hôpital mais
je sais pas si vous réalisez ce qui se
passe moi je le dis et olivier ferrand
devrait démissionner je demande sa
démission
ce ministre est dangereux pour les
français dangereux je pèse mes mots il
faut réintégrer les soignants il faut
faire des tests elle déteste c'est pas
compliqué
[Musique]